el presidente de caixa it sostiene que
todo tiene legitimidad y ha negado las
acusaciones de que su decisión de
despedir al primer ministro y suspender
al parlamento equivale a un golpe de
estado
he asumido la responsabilidad estoy
asumiendo una responsabilidad histórica
aquellos que afirman que este asunto
está relacionado con un golpe de estado
deben revisar sus lecciones en la
constitución talca
se ha visto a la gente a no salir a las
calles prometió que cualquier oposición
violenta se enfrentaría con la fuerza y
también reforzó las restricciones de
kobe 19 en cuanto a reuniones el primer
ministro destituido y jamie
acordó dejar que el presidente eligiera
a su sucesor diciendo que no quería
causar problemas más temprano el lunes
estallaron refriegas frente al
parlamento de túnez cuando los
partidarios del presidente se
enfrentaron a los partidarios del
principal partido del país las
decisiones del presidente de caixa y no
son correctas contra la constitución y
la realidad nos traen de nuevo a 1954
ver el parlamento cerrado por tanques es
una vergüenza la decisión se tomó luego
de meses de estancamiento político y
crecientes tensiones el impacto de la
pandemia junto con el alto desempleo
resultó en protestas masivas contra el
gobierno durante el fin de semana muchas
potencias extranjeras han expresado su
preocupación por las acciones del
presidente said instando a túnez a no
poner en peligro
gracia de 10 años